well The Wall Street example is a very
simple system that all creatures operate
on and that is in building the emotional
system the emotional system does not
come preassembled you have to learn how
to assemble it and you do that through
experience so if you're rewarded you
tend to repeat whatever you got rewarded
for if you're punished you tend to avoid
whatever you got punished for and on
Wall Street if you make up some
cockamamie mortgage scheme and you get a
billion dollars for it you go wow that's
really cool let's do that again which is
exactly it's a simplified version of
what happened on Wall Street but
essentially these guys saw a thing that
they could do these mortgage default
insurance schemes in a rising market
that every time they did it it rewarded
them and so they did it again and again
and again and it's like having fire
insurance on your house only a thousand
other guys have fire insurance on your
house too so when your house burns down
the company that insured you goes bust
because it can't pay everybody so that's
a very simplified scheme in which you
get rewarded and do again the wrong
thing when when you say that someone is
experienced often what you mean is that
they have done the wrong thing more
times than you have but one of the other
systems that I talked about in the book
is the mental model system and I'll give
you an example of a really bad mistake
that I made using mental models when I
was a little kid my grandmother had an
ashtray that looked like a rattlesnake
it was a beautiful thing made out of
stone and it was very realistic and I
had this model in my head of a
rattlesnake that was you know benign it
was a harmless thing and it had these
nice emotional associations with my
childhood and my grandmother and frankly
I never thought about it again I don't
know where it went but one day as an
adult I was hiking in the Santa Monica
Mountains and I came across the ruin of
a stone house and I I thought oh cool
I'll look for a souvenir here I'll find
some old tool or something to bring home
with me from this ruined house in this
stone rubble and I started searching
around and then all of a sudden lo and
behold there was my grandmother's
ashtray I'm like what a miracle my
grandmother's ashtray how did that
happen
and I reached out to pick it up and then
I saw its tongue come out and of course
I realized the very stupid mistake that
I've made because I had all this
intellectual knowledge that could have
prevented me from doing that but that
didn't because I was operating on the
mental model the closest association I
had and it was stored away I hadn't
thought about it for decades and it was
my grandmother's ashtray so I knew
intellectually for example that the
chances of finding my grandmother's
ashtray anywhere in the known universe
were approximately zero
I knew also there that I was in the
mountain wilderness where rattlesnakes
are really common in California I knew
that they liked to poke around in stone
ruins cuz mice lived there I knew all
this stuff and it did me no good so this
is what I mean when I say smart people
do stupid things this is a the type of
mistake that certain scientists call an
intelligent mistake because all my
learning my most important learning
caused the mistake